[Music]
you may think Bitcoin is silly but it's
just as silly as gold we have a system
in place where we know how to mine it we
pull it out of the earth yes it's very
dangerous yes it costs human lives but
like we care about this shiny metal and
we've just agreed as a society that this
is a store of value so at a very basic
minimum when you have a store of value
that you can transport out of a country
if God forbid you're under duress
you can carry this out much more easily
than than the gold and and so here is in
in the most boring way possible in
argument for why crypto and I mean in
particular in this case Bitcoin is good
is useful and it's here to say
I'm Alexis Ohanian probably best known
for founding Reddit I started the
company rat out of college 2005.
I returned to the company back in 2014
as executive chairman for the turnaround
and then I left for good in 2020.
[Music]
I was going to be a lawyer and then I
walked out of that LSAT it's a true
story walk the hell out of that LSAT 20
minutes into it because I was like this
is terrible I'm I don't want to be here
went to the Waffle House on 29 in
Charlottesville Virginia sat down got my
order and I'm sitting there and I'm just
like
can't be a lawyer and that was where I
decided I was like I can't do this I
quit I was like I'm not taking any more
lsats like I'm done and went back to my
dorm and started convincing my roommate
to join me in starting a company it took
like a year to convince him to join me
but
I just knew I had to be an entrepreneur
[Music]
these days I'm doing my life's work at
776 which is a technology company that
deploys Venture Capital so I have always
been what I'd like to think is a
pragmatic supporter of crypto about half
of the 776 portfolio is in some way
investing in crypto or blockchain
Technologies
when 2005 I'm starting Reddit
web2 was the jargony phrase what did it
mean it really just meant that we had
some new technology back then it was
called Ajax just some fancy JavaScript
that let me design a website where you
could have these up and down arrows and
comments that you could click on in real
time and see them change
everyone in web 2 was in a way following
zuck's lead right I think Facebook had
launched maybe a year before us and then
Twitter launched a few years after us
but we were all following the same model
which was
grow as fast as you can
and you'll figure it out later which
meant then eventually you'll have enough
users you have enough users to run ads
and I was never happy with that it never
felt good we tried our best to build you
know ads that users didn't hate because
they could comment on them and they
could vote on them but it always felt
like an ugly hack
what I realized there was we were early
and right in a lot of ways but we had a
deeply flawed business model advertising
and
web 2 allowed for social media allowed
for user generated content allowed for
anyone to say hey I've got a funny story
to tell and I think it could be just as
funny as anyone else's even though I
didn't go to a journalism school or
didn't go to a writing school or
whatever and
we just didn't figure out a business
model that worked for it I think having
a front row seat to building Reddit as
well as building the communities of
Reddit specifically has exercised a lot
of muscles around intuition for
community and as communities grew
we sort of Cobble together ways for
businesses to go around it let's start
with the Community First let's build
technology around that energy let's
build a brand around that energy and
here we go
[Music]
so back in 2012 I was working at Y
combinator which was the same
accelerator that first funded me back in
2005 when I was a CEO starting Reddit
and I remembered meeting this young man
Brian Armstrong he had just left Airbnb
he was their head of fraud clearly a
very smart guy Airbnb was clearly a very
successful company
he was choosing to leave
start something new to be the best and
safest way to buy crypto online and I
thought okay someone is smart at a
company this successful who still wants
to just step away and build something he
believed was going to be his life's work
that's something I needed to lean in and
learn more about so I went to the first
place you would expect which is Reddit
and visited the r slash Bitcoin
Community to start educating myself and
to start seeing you know the audience
there on Reddit has always been among
the earliest adopters of technology and
so not everything goes viral not
everything goes mainstream but here was
a community that was very frustrated
because it was very hard to buy this
cryptocurrency that they believed in and
Brian Armstrong was the the first one to
really put his hand up and say I want to
do this I want to do this above board
I'm going to put my name on the website
and I want people to feel safe buying
this asset
at the time I thought he'd probably
still get shut down by the government at
some point I'm sitting here reading that
white paper thinking wow really like
people are gonna care about this but
there was just enough because there were
enough redditors who already cared about
it and thought this is powerful this is
a big deal I thought you know what the
technology is interesting enough the
white paper is is sort of intellectually
sound and there's a community of very
passionate redditors who believe in this
and if anyone's going to do it Brian
seemed like the right one she's very
lucky to have invested that early
[Music]
the technology is a medium and I compare
it to paper in a way that I think works
pretty well for folks
right like
4 000 years ago someone is inventing
Papyrus right and they're sitting there
and he you're probably more likely she
is like yo I can take a thing and write
on this and give it to you and now it's
yours right that's pretty cool now if
you were to go back in time right now
and explain that today paper is used for
everything from and we'd have to explain
what a a script is you have to explain
what a trading card is you have to
explain what tissue paper is you'd have
to explain what you'd have to explain to
them that there is a piece of paper here
in the United States that is so
important we wrote down some words on it
a few hundred years ago and it's like a
sacred document and then there's
actually literally a sacred document
that's been printed millions of times
all over the world and it's the basis of
an entire religion that that people
share like
the the Leaps and Bounds of what this
simple medium could do could not have
been imagined at that time and so now I
think in the next few years
we'll start to see some really
boring applications for this technology
think of it like paper that starts to
compound in value and utility for people
where again they shouldn't need to know
the underlying Tech just like they
didn't need to know Ajax they don't need
to know if it's an ft it just needs to
work it needs to deliver a delightful
experience
that's it if we stick to this metaphor
of nft is paper then paper can have a
cultural value but also utility the
Michael Jordan first basketball game
ticket stub is is a perfect example of
this right it is a piece of paper it had
utility
a few decades ago because you knew which
seat your butt went into and when you
got there no one else was sitting there
right that's clear utility
today it has cultural value because it
was Michael Jordan's first game and it's
worth hundreds of thousands of dollars
and those are the channels where we're
going to see the value in nfts over
these next years
[Music]
in Tech broadly
it's going to be a rocky Year I wish it
weren't the case but I think it's going
to be a rockier and CEOs
are going to be looking at
a very different scenario for their next
fundraise than ever before or at least
that I've seen I you know 0809 is
probably the best comp I was a I was at
Y combinator at the time and and
watching companies like stripe and
Airbnb get started in that mess
was so inspiring because those CEOs and
those companies were so lean and so mean
and had to earn every user and every
dollar and were rejected a hundred times
by investors but it made them
so much stronger and so much more
formidable and so the thing we've been
impressing Upon Our Founders frankly
since the end of last year is that this
is the time to really really pursue
this kind of Excellence within your org
it's not about squandering money it's
not about chasing you know radical
valuations it's about delighting your
users shipping building a performance
culture in your org and the good news is
you know we're still a young firm
ourselves and we're we're living a lot
of these values ourselves the companies
in the portfolio are still quite young
and then the founders we're meeting now
and I really believe in the next year or
two are going to be hardened in a very
different way and as much pain as this
economic uncertainty is unfortunately
going to create
that same pain will create some
tremendous companies to get started and
I'm I'm hopeful for those because we
need those companies we need those
companies to further push us in space
Tech and climate Tech and software and
yes even even crypto
you know I've lived through a lot of
Cycles now a lot of crypto Winters and
every single winter I actually relish
the chance
because you're spending time with real
Builders who are sober and focused the
first time CEO that I meet today who's
21 fresh out of college
just like I was are so much smarter than
I was and not just in the obvious way
that every generation you would hope
right two decades later is much smarter
they are much more wise because they are
the first generation to have grown up in
this era in this age using it every day
seeing it how affected them in school
seeing how it affected them like they
have this to see I think every
generation feels this I think they will
undo or at a minimum learn from a lot of
mistakes that we made and I'm here to
help them as much as possible
I feel very fortunate to see now in the
last two years the the progress and the
success and all the good fortune we've
had just makes me think like
I mean in a way it makes me think gosh
if I didn't do this sooner but but I'm
I'm happy to be in the place I'm in
right now and it's it's been fun and
it's incredibly satisfying and I have a
kid who I promised two years ago when I
resigned the way I did in protests from
Reddit that I was going to do everything
I could
to not just keep doing my best
professionally but do so in a way that
was going to make her proud one day and
make her want to you know obviously
she's got a mother to be very proud of
but I'm competitive and I want her to be
just as proud of me too
folks for years would be like hey
redhead I love reddit reddit and then
for a while it was I love your wife they
still do that every now and then it's
like I love Olympia which is nice but a
little weird but it was the first time a
few months ago someone said hey I love
angel City FC thank you so much and that
felt great and it would make me so happy
if if that were my legacy
the Focus right now is 776 Angel City
happens to be a part of that but I'm
really
I'm in a very fortunate place right now
it's the firm's only two years old but
the the success we've had the Tailwinds
everything has been it feels like this
energy has been compounding in such
magnificent ways and and yes we do early
stage investing I get to spend a lot of
my time Building Products that helps our
team work fully remotely helps us
support our Founders better than anyone
in the game
and
you know I started a foundation I didn't
call the Ohanian Family Foundation
because that was lame I called it the
776 Foundation because it's just it's a
better brand and and started making you
know started building my philanthropic
Legacy the the rest of my life is going
to be spent deploying Capital whether it
is for-profit on the Venture side
and we'll do it better than anyone or
philanthropically on the foundation side
and I hope we can do that obviously also
better than anyone and that's it that's
what I want the Google search results to
be and maybe Olympia's dad that'd be
cool too
[Music]